[APPLAUSE]
VINT CERF: Hi there.
First of all, I want to tell you
that Carla LaFever and I have
known Gary for a long time.
We are all part of the
MCI community for awhile.
And Carla really believes
in what Gary's doing.
And I can prove this,
because this morning,
she came into with a
giant sack of vegetables
that she grew in her own garden.
So she's practicing
what Gary preaches.
Let me tell you a
little bit about Gary.
I came across Gary
Oppenheimer back
in the mid 1980s, when
we were both at MCI mail.
And he noticed that this was
a communication company that
wasn't communicating
well with its customers.
So he connected the
dots, by creating
the first electronic newsletter.
Well, he's done it again.
Today, most people
think about hunger.
But few about food waste,
that is it's cause.
So we spent a great deal of time
and money to feed the hungry,
without actually solving hunger.
Gary identified the problem that
most people never knew existed.
The food waste, by
tens of millions
of growers with overly
abundant gardens,
while their nearby
neighbors went hungry.
His nonprofit, AmpleHarvest.org,
created a whole new supply
channel, for the
American food safety net.
Not by buying and
distributing food,
as it had usually been done.
But instead, by connecting
those dots to unleash,
well, the pent up supply of
freely available, locally
grown, fresh food, and
community goodwill,
on a sustainable
and life long basis.
And believe me, sustainable
was really important there.
AmpleHarvest.org
leverages its technology,
and many of the
Google resources,
to pair growers with
local food pantries.
It addresses both food waste as
the underlying cause of hunger,
as well was hunger itself.
They use the internet to bring
extreme market efficiency
to what is in the past has been
a very inefficient process.
It's an inherently scalable and
potentially global solution.
It makes the best use
of precious resources
we have today.
The long term outcome
is an improvement
in the future of health, and by
extension, wealth of America.
All at no cost to the grower.
Many individuals think they
can't make a difference today,
but this whole process
proves them wrong.
Gary uses technology to create
the opportunity for others
to improve the
future of America,
and by extension, the
rest of the world.
In this multiplier
effect, the distributed
disruptive technology can be
hugely impactful and extremely
efficient in addressing some
of our pressing problems.
Before I close, here's a little
bit of information about Gary.
He is a self described
'aging geek;' a CNN hero;
lecture and speaker,
including a TEDx;
Points of Light Tribute
winner; Purpose Prize fellow;
Huffington Post Greatest
Person of the Day;
and 2011 Game Changer,
winner of the Russell Berrie
Foundation's Making
a Difference Award;
winner the Glenwood 2011 Wave
of the Future Award winner
of the 2012 Elfenworks in
Harmony with Hope award;
Echoing Green semifinalist; and
someone I recently nominated
for the World Food prize.
He now makes his home in the
mountains of northern New
Jersey, after having
lived on a boat,
on the Hudson River in
Manhattan, since 1978.
He's also a master gardener;
Rutgers environmental steward;
former community
garden director;
a town environmental
commissioner-- I didn't even
know they had such things;
a small scale farmer;
a long distance cyclist; and the
founder and executive director
of the nonprofit called
AmpleHarvest.org.
It's not often that a
small tech based charity
gets the awards and accolades,
including from the White
House, and the recognition
that they have.
Google's technology, including
AdWords, Map Engine, Alerts,
Knowledge Grabs, Street
View, YouTube, and more,
are all a part of what
makes AmpleHarvest.org
work brilliantly.
Google's been a proud
partner in this effort.
And I hope you too
will find a way
to help support
AmpleHarvest.org's work.
And I give you now,
Gary Oppenheimer.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY OPPENHEIMER:
Thank you very much.
Vint, thank you so much.
I hope you're still seeing this.
And I appreciate you and Carla
taking the time, and especially
Vint, thank you for doing
this on your birthday.
This is Vint's birthday.
So--
VINT CERF: Hey, Gary.
I'm 71.
That means I'm in my prime.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: I think
you will be in your prime
for a very long time.
But thank you.
Thank you very, very much.
And I'm hoping that
for those of you
choose to do any
tweeting about this talk,
that you'll send this out to
your network of the people
that you communicate with.
We'll going to be talking about
four different topics today.
Food waste, as Vint had said;
the impact of food waste;
the solution; and what's
going on in the future.
We're going to have this
in a three part, today.
I'm going to talk
for about 15 minutes.
Then Kim.
And by the way, Kim, thank you
very much for setting this up.
I appreciate it.
But Kim's going to
do a Q&A up here.
And then, for about half
an hour, give or take,
I'd like to open this up to
questions from the audience,
from all of you.
So please think about things
you want to ask about;
questions, concerns, ideas-- I
really would like to hear them.
Everything comes
with a tipping point.
This was one of my
several tipping points.
This was a photograph
in "The New York
Times," 2008 by Bill Marsh.
This represents
the amount of food
lost in America by a
family of four, in a month.
About a pound a person, a day.
At that time, it was about
100 billion pounds a year.
This is something that
everybody owns, from the farmer
to the consumer.
So this was what sort
of caught my eye.
More recently on discussions
about food waste,
the USDA issued this report.
This is only about a
month old actually.
And their look back
report, going back to 2010,
is just plain frightening.
In 2010, America lost $161
billion worth of food,
in one year.
We talk about our budget,
how it affects the economy.
Imagine if somebody had
to write a check for $161
billion dollars.
We flush that away
in food waste.
A third of our food
didn't get consumed.
And that's a significant
chunk of what
we could have been giving people
across America as the nutrition
that they need.
In 2012, the National
Resource Defense Counsel
issued this report.
Now although the report
came before the USDA report,
it's actually using later data.
So the two of them
swap a little bit.
Their computations
were 40% of the food
in this country is not consumed.
4% of the energy American
reduces got lost.
32% of the water
we have was wasted.
Because water is a
huge part of our-- use
of water for agriculture.
And it represented about
20 pounds a person, of food
a month.
So this is hurting everybody
across the country.
This is from that NRDC report.
I'd like you to focus for
a minute on the large red
and green pies on there.
That's fruit and vegetables,
in billions of pounds.
So looking at about 18 and
1/2 billion pounds of fruit,
about 25 billion pounds of
vegetables that didn't get
consumed.
We all own this problem.
As I said, it
starts at the farm,
and it ends at
the kitchen table.
Everybody has a piece
of this problem.
What was not in any of
these reports however,
were the people like
myself, and maybe
like you, who are home
and community gardeners.
No one's ever really looked at
that information in any detail,
about the food that
we have, and the food
that we're not actually using.
The National
Gardening Association
issued a report very recently.
And we're now up to 42 million
people in this country growing
food in home and
community gardens.
That's about a little more than
a third of all the households.
To 17% in the past five years.
And most interestingly,
the average gardener
harvests about 300
pounds of food a year.
Now it's not 300 pounds
over the course of a year,
because we don't grow
over the course of a year.
That's compressed into
your growing season.
So you're waiting for
maybe nine months.
And then in three
months, you're dealing
with a staggering
amount of food,
which is typically more
than you can use, preserve,
or you can share with friends.
This is not just in the suburbs.
An increasing amount of
people in urban settings
are growing food.
And even in the younger
generation, Millennials,
it's a huge increase
in the number
of people who are growing
food for themselves.
The food waste on
the grower side
comes from enthusiasm,
over planting,
not being able to
share with friends,
I've discovered personally--
there's only so many cucumbers
you can give to friends and
still have them call you
a friend.
Choosing not to preserve in can.
And just getting
bored and overwhelmed,
come August and September, the
tomatoes are still producing,
and you're fed up.
The stuff is left to rot,
or goes into the garbage.
So what's the impact
of this food waste?
This is not a political map.
Let me start with this.
Those red states,
these 23 states,
if you add the combined
population of the states,
you're looking at
the number of people
in this country who
are food insecure.
Food insecurity, by
the way, means either
that you're hungry, or you're
at real risk of being hungry.
So one out of every six Americas
are considered food insecure.
That's about 50 million people.
One out of every four
children in this country
are growing up in a
food insecure home.
And in some
populations, it's one
out of every three children.
These kids who don't eat
well, don't do well in school.
Their parents, who
don't eat well,
don't do well in the workplace.
So the country is hurting,
today's economy and tomorrow's
economy, by not
nourishing the people
that need the food the most.
The impact from the health
perspective is staggering.
People are arguing about
the Affordable Health Care
Act, Obamacare.
Really what's
coming down the pike
are staggering numbers on
obesity, type 2 diabetes,
hypertension, and other
food related illnesses.
Things that we could
prevent and actually fix,
are trending to the worst.
In part because
of the food that's
available to too many people.
I had a brief chat with General
Clark in October, retired.
Three out of four
young people who
apply to the
military service are
rejected, because
they're not fit to serve.
How does the food
system work today?
The food safety net,
the food bank system.
If you look at the chart, let me
see if the pointers is working.
It does, all right.
The red dot in the middle
is feeding America.
That is an organization
that represents
and sort of coordinates 203
food banks across America.
Food banks being large
warehouse type operations,
that collect and
redistribute food.
They connect to 33,500 food
pantries, soup Kitchens,
and other similar, food
distribution agencies
across the country.
That system works very
nicely for processed food.
You want to have
bread, corn flakes,
things-- works
very, very nicely.
One of the problems, is
however, the distribution cycle.
If you look at that red line
on the bottom marked time,
it can take days
or weeks for food
to move from that food
bank to a food pantry.
The result is, that while
processed canned jars,
boxes work fine, fresh
food doesn't work,.
Which is why, when you go to a
food drive, you're always told,
jars, cans, boxes--
no fresh food.
The result is that 42
million people like myself,
who grow food in
home gardens often
end up just tossing it away.
If it's more than you can use.
You either compost it, or
worse, it goes into a landfill,
and creates
environmental problems.
In March 2009, I had an idea.
The idea was, what if we
could enable these people have
too much food in
their home gardens--
myself included, by the way--
to be able to donate food
to the people in the
community who most need it.
This came out of a discussion
I had in the community garden
I was running.
I said to these
people, if you're
going to have an ample
harvest, the least we could do
is give it away to people.
It just rolled off my tongue.
That was another tipping point.
Because I found an
AmpleHarvest.org was
an available domain,
so I grabbed it.
I had spent the
$9 on that, and I
couldn't let that go to waste.
So that brought me to here.
The idea was to enable
the food to be donated,
and nobody had ever really done
that before, on a large scale.
But the vision I
had, the idea was,
let's bypass the
choke point, and let's
get that food
directly to the food
pantries in the communities.
Because the food-- you can
live in northern Vermont,
and be a three hour drive
from the regional food bank.
Or you could go down the
street or across town,
to the nearby food pantry.
So that's how AmpleHarvest.org
was actually born.
The idea was to both be a in the
cloud registry of food pantries
across America-- an opt-in
registry by the way.
This is something
where each pantry
says we want to
be a part of this.
And a search engine.
And by the way, Google
was an inspiration
from that perspective in my
mind, for how to build this.
A search engine to
actually find the food
pantries in your neighborhood.
And then for you to actually
take the food directly
to the food pantry yourself.
Were not involved.
So we have zero logistics.
The hope and the intent was
to create a system whereby
once you knew you could and
should donate the food--
and we enabled it--
you would do so
for the rest of gardening life.
And on top of that, you
would tell your friends
who are complaining that they've
grown too much food, that they
had the opportunity
to donate the food.
This is what AmpleHarvest.org
looks like today.
It's looks very
familiar for those
of you familiar
with Google Maps.
It's basically a search engine.
There's a database of pantries.
You pick the pantry
that you want.
You find the pantry,
and now you've
got a direct connection
with that food pantry.
One of the pantries did
something I hadn't expected.
It was His Hands Food Pantry.
This particular
pantry registered
and they did something in their
listing I haven't expected.
They talk back to the
community and said, hey,
we need stuff from you.
It was the first
time I saw that.
And it dawned on me,
my god, these pantries
are talking back
to the community.
They're telling the community
what they really need.
That created a whole
new market efficiency,
and we're building the new
AmpleHarvest.org you'll
be learning about in a few
minutes, around the idea
that not only can
you donate food,
but the pantries can
actually help guide you
to what they most
importantly need.
So the innovations are all over
the place, as it turned out.
I built this and then I
looked back and said, my god,
look at all these things
that are in there.
The food system gets improve.
Behavior gets changed.
The environment is
impacted, and the impact
on society as a
whole, has changed.
But basically, it's a very
empowering resource for anybody
to be able to go,
and to say, I can
be the game changer
for my own community.
For the first time, food
pantries across America,
that almost never
have fresh food,
suddenly began to
have the opportunity
to offer fresh
food to the people
in their own communities.
This is in Bridgeport,
Connecticut.
It's an urban city.
Somebody donated food that
would have been thrown away,
to a food pantry.
Just imagine what
that type of change
that happens, whether
you're in Bridgeport or New
York, or near the city or
suburb, or rural setting.
It works all over.
So AmpleHarvest.org, I had
this idea in March of 2009,
and it took me seven weeks from
that idea date to get it built.
And to get it rolled out.
And by the way, at the time
it was done by three people.
A woman who donated her time
in town for the front end
of the pretty part,
where it looks good.
A gentleman who put together his
time for building the database.
And I did the contents.
So basically, if it's
pretty, Maureen did it.
If it's data, Josh did it.
And if you can
read it, I did it.
Once it was put together
and we were at this point,
the first pantry signed up.
I started making heavy
use if Google Alerts,
to start telling me about other
pantries and other connections,
to start spreading the word.
This was 100
pantries on June 20.
Now what's interesting is that
I had gone to Google and said,
do you guys have anything
you can help us with?
I got this really cool idea.
And the answer was yes.
Google has an AdWords
grant program.
We applied.
We got fast tracked through
that system really fast,
and whoever I owe
thanks to, thank you.
And so in the time between
launch and this date,
AmpleHarvest.org was
already up on AdWords.
And I have to say, I knew
nothing about AdWords myself.
It was a quick learn
I had to go through.
And at this point,
AmpleHarvest.org
was now a one person
operation, largely me.
This is 500 pantries in August.
We had 1,000 pantries
in October, 2015,
which just happened
to be World Food Day.
2,000 pantries, and today, we're
at nearly 7,000 food pantries.
One out of every
five in America.
This means that people who
live in these communities,
for the first time ever,
are able to donate food
to a food pantry in
their own community.
Media coverage went off
the roof, it was wonderful.
Instead of food going
into a waste stream,
people were donating
food from home gardens
Small farmers were
donating food,
and it was getting
into the pantry system.
And by the way,
just so everybody,
knows the feedback
from the pantries
has been that when the
fresh food shows up,
it's the first thing
the clients go for.
I mean there's been
this idea that,
do people really
want fresh food?
They do.
And it's the first
that they go for.
So for the future,
you're looking
at the new AmpleHarvest.org.
We're announcing it
right here, right now.
AmpleHarvest.org as a
website and as a system
is being rebuilt.
This is our new look.
This is our new logo.
So I hope you like it.
This is what the
new AmpleHarvest.org
page is going to look like.
It's built around Google
technologies, a whole lot
of which I don't
know a lot about.
But I've got an amazing
tech team working on it,
with help from Google
engineers, which
they've just been wonderful.
So this is what the
new AmpleHarvest.org
heart of our website is
going to be looking like.
It's going to be out
in a month or so.
The programs that we have in
place for AmpleHarvest.org;
it's going to be using
time management push
technology, a whole bunch
of new Google things.
We're going to in the future be
building GleaningHarvest.org,
which will be
AmpleHarvest.org on steroids.
It's going to be
a resource that's
not going to work with
the home gardener,
but with an even larger
amount of food left behind
on farms across
America, farmers harvest
their stuff and a
few things happen.
One of which is the machinery
leaves a lot in the ground.
Another is the prices
drop, and the farmer says,
I'm not even gonna
bother harvesting it.
There are many different
things-- carrots, too long,
too short.
Cosmetically, not perfect.
Leaning organizations are
going to be getting a spotlight
from gleaningharvest.org.
We're going to be
building this whole thing
on Google technology.
And for the first time, we'll
be able to connect gleaning
organizations to the
farms, just like we now
connect home gardeners
to the pantries.
And we'll go further into
ending this scourge, really,
of wasted food in the country.
Let me see if I can
get this working.
Because this is something
that was-- well,
this is the level of
support that we've gotten--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The response to this initiative
has been overwhelming.
All kinds of faith communities
have been stepping up.
Muslim community leaders are
hosting sports tournaments,
to encourage young
people to get active.
The Jewish Community
Centers Association
is working with JCCs around
the country to grow gardens,
and to get fresh food
in under served areas.
And they're creating early
child wellness programs.
Groups like the National
Council of Churches
have joined with an organization
called AmpleHarvest,
to help gardeners donate
fresh produce to 4,700
of their local food pantries.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GARY OPPENHEIMER:
This was a year
or two-- this was
about two years ago.
And Firstlady Stafford
contact me and said,
you may want to
watch the speech.
My wife didn't know
why I was screaming.
But thanks to the White House.
We've had wonderful support
from the White House,
both the president's office
and the first lady's office.
As of last week,
AmpleHarvest.org
is now included in Feds
Feed Families, which
is the US government's
own food drive.
Given the size of the US
government, the largest
employer in America.
This means that about one
million home gardeners,
if government employees
represent the average American,
will be learning
about the opportunity
that they can donate food.
So this is a huge jump
for reducing food waste
and improving the
nutrition in the country.
Next month,
AmpleHarvest.org is going
to be included in the
Google Economic Impact
report, which is a
huge honor for us.
And we're again going to
be doing Skip The Flowers.
And when you are
looking to do events
where you're going to have
flowers-- whether it's
a holiday table or an
event, consider the idea
of actually using
arrangements of whole fruits
and vegetables
instead of flowers.
And just donate that food the
next day to a food pantry.
So what is made
AmpleHarvest.org so special?
It's simple.
It's a no-brainer.
It's very efficient.
We have no logistics.
Everything is local
in the community.
It universal.
It works every place, and
the resources you need
are every place.
And most important, it fixes
some really critical problems
in our country.
There are some other
really important things
about what makes
AmpleHarvest.org so important--
so good.
One of the key
things-- I'm gonna
go into that more
in a moment-- is
that it is so efficient
from a cost perspective.
It cost so little, compared
to any other program.
These have been our partners
that AmpleHarvest.org
has relied-- has benefited from.
Google of course, being
an immense partner.
We're now a Google--
the largest grant
Google has, in terms of
AdWords, $40,000 a month,
so thank you all.
BV, which is a wine
company out west,
has been our biggest
supporter, in terms of income.
There really big on pushing and
encouraging innovative ideas
to deal with hunger.
And as a matter of
fact, when this is over,
you're going to enjoy the
fruits of their labor,
in the back of the room.
So now we go to this other piece
of this no good deed done goes
unpunished sort of idea.
And that is that,
I've discovered
that in the nonprofit world,
great ideas don't receive quite
the reception they receive
in the for-profit world.
So what we've discovered--
it's been interesting,
is that when you
have a new idea,
people look it the old way.
The typical food bank model
is, how many pounds of food?
How many meals did you serve?
That really doesn't work here.
And as a matter of
fact, here, this
is the questions that we
realize become really important.
And I did a thought
experiment, by the way,
that brought me to this.
Because I originally thought
this was a hunger program.
It was, the obvious thing to
me was, we're feeding people.
So I have this very
quick thought experiment
I want to do with all
of you for a minute.
Imagine every food
pantry in America--
all 33,500 are on
AmpleHarvest.org.
And imagine every grower
in America-- all 42 million
knew about their
opportunity to donate food.
And imagine if there was
a drought or a blight,
and every garden
in America died,
nothing was harvested that
year, are we a success,
is AmpleHarvest.org a
success or a failure?
So a show of hands, how many say
AmpleHarvest.org is a success?
How many say failure?
All right, you had the
same idea that I had.
The fact that the
food wasn't, couldn't
be moved, had nothing
to do with us.
We had set up the conduit
for the food to move.
And that's where I
came to the realization
that the heart of
AmpleHarvest.org
is not so much feeding people,
but getting people fed.
It's a supply side channel
for the food bank system.
Once I got to that
realization-- this
has been part of this
problem of being in the weeds
and not being in the
forest, I started
to understand the
really bigger impact
of what this program
is all about.
And the people who are working
on it, what we all share.
That red dot in
that orange circle
represents a single soup
kitchen Washington, DC.
9 mile radius circle
around it, 250 square miles
and the question
is, how many growers
live in 250 square miles?
Depends on where you are,
but you know it's not zero.
We've created the
opportunity for those growers
to donate food to that pantry.
And then look how many dots
are on the map right now.
That's the amount of opportunity
that AmpleHarvest.org now
represents, and
growing, to change
the future of the country.
The problem was-- and
a more interesting one,
from the support
perspective, in terms
of getting funding
from foundations.
Your typical food
funding organization,
working with a food
organization, works like this.
They ask for $100 thousand,
$10,000 goes operation.
$90,000 goes to food.
You feed the families,
you run out of food,
you come back again.
You ask for more money.
And that loop goes
on and on and on.
And your bean
counters look at it,
and they say, wow,
only 10% overhead,
that's really kind of cool.
Go with it.
Then a scrappy young nonprofit
comes along and says,
well, we don't need the
$90 thousand for the food.
The food's already
in the community.
We do need money for staff and
technology, so $10,000 please.
You look at it first,
you say $10,000
to permanently fix a
system that doesn't
need to be refunded over
and over and over and over
and over again?
And you say, really cool.
And then your bean counter
comes along and says,
wait a minute,
it's 100% overhead.
And suddenly, the bean counter
says, we can't help you out,
because you're all overhead.
Innovative ideas, I've
discovered in the charity
world, with innovative
models, often
struggle up against the
idea that with innovation,
comes a roadblock from the
old ways of doing things.
This is exactly the
type of PowerPoint slide
you're not supposed to do.
So I did it.
Scan on the left hand side.
And you're just going to
pick out one or two of them.
These are emails that we've
received from people who say,
I need help.
On the right hand
hide, those are
emails from people who
say, how can I help?
This is America, side by side.
50 people needing, help
42 million people saying,
they can help.
And all that's been
separating them
has been the lack of
awareness that they already
could be helping each other,
which is what AmpleHarvest.org
has fixed, and continues to fix.
Google has been an amazing
partner for AmpleHarvest.org.
We're blessed and honored.
And we want to-- just to
let you know how Googlers,
how people here and people
watching can also help.
One of the things is
AmpleHarvest.org/local,
which is something open to
anybody and everybody across
the country.
The idea that there
are things you
can do in your own community
to cement the AmpleHarvest.org
model in your community.
It takes a few hours of work.
And it's a step by
step type of process.
The second thing is
things specific to Google,
including on that
Google page there,
that fact that Google now
matches all donations to Hobbes
AmpleHarvest.org, up to $6,000.
I do speakers, and
also, we're looking
for more engagement from people.
So people who want to help
out have ideas, suggestions,
whatever, I hope that
it's a type of thing that
will move and inspire people.
The heart behind
AmpleHarvest.org
is the fact that
people are able to do
things they thought
they couldn't do.
Everybody wants to
be somebody special.
I-- as a kid, I
wanted to be Superman.
I used to fly into
my parents' bed.
We grow up, eventually
thinking that that's just
not the way it is.
We have real lives.
The reality is that
AmpleHarvest.org's model
is enabling anybody
to be the game
changer in their own community.
I was actually--
CNN had asked me
at one point, what's it
feel like to be a hero?
And I said, it's
really not about me.
This is about 42
million people being
the hero in their own community.
When I was a kid, my mother
loved Leonard Bernstein,
the conductor.
And I never got it.
I saw a guy with his back to
the audience, waving a stick.
And I said to her, the musicians
are making all the music.
This guy's waving a stick.
AmpleHarvest.org is
waving the stick.
But it's 42 million
people across the country
could make the difference in
the future of the country,
the health of the
children, the economy,
and the welfare of the nation.
So I want to thank you
all very, very much.
And I think Kim and I are
gonna have a brief question
and answer.
And then open it up to
questions from all of you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KIM: Thanks, very, Gary.
That was very inspiring.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Thank you.
KIM: Now, I'm going to
ask you some intensely
personal question.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: OK.
KIM: They're not really.
So you are a techie, a
gardener, an environmentalist.
And then you created a
hunger food waste program.
How did that happen?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: I hate waste.
Seriously, I grew up with,
finish what's on your plate.
Kids are starving in Europe.
And I saw the waste, and
I like solving problems.
I mean, Vint had
talked about the fact
that when I was a part of
MCI, I saw a company that
had produced MCI Mail, a
really wonderful email service.
But they weren't communicating
with their own customers.
And I said, let me send
them out a newsletter.
So I created the
newsletter, which
maybe means I may have been one
of the first creators of spam.
So my apologies.
But the point was,
I see disconnects.
And this was a clear disconnect.
And it was an easy
one to fix too.
Because nothing you
had to be built.
It was just connecting the dots.
And that's what got me to here.
KIM: Cool.
So since you've created
AmpleHarvest.org,
what's been the most surprising
thing that you've learned?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: What I
was just talking about.
The difficulty
innovative charities
have in getting support.
I've seen lots of
other charities
out there, with really great
ideas in all sorts of realms,
struggle up against the fact
that they're doing new things.
And the old way is
what's more accepted.
Imagine for a minute, if you
built a better mouse trap,
and you came to a
for-profit company,
and they threw money
you to market it.
And in a not for profit
world, the better mousetrap,
they say, that's nice,
but we fund cats.
This is in the problem.
And I think it holds back the
improvement of our society.
Because people who
have really good ideas
get stymied, by
the fact that they
can't be as impactful
as they could be.
Just for lack of the old system
not catching up with them.
There's a funding curve that
lags behind the innovation
curve.
That's been very frustrating.
KIM: Well, maybe you
answered my next question.
Which was, what's your
biggest disappointment?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: In that vein,
the biggest disappointment
is, we couldn't have done
more than we've done so far.
This model, and others
like it-- by the way,
this model is a no-brainer
for the country.
And if we had the
staff, and the resources
we need, we could have--
as impactful as we've been,
we could have been much more
impactful, many times over.
I was actually approached at
a conference that I was at.
And we went in the
room with the big boys.
You know, Oxfam and Red Cross.
And somebody said, how
much money do you need?
And I said 500.
And the guy said million?
I said, no, thousand.
And he just gave
me a blank stare.
It was sort of like,
how can you do something
like-- this-- that's been
the frustrating thing.
We're going to deal with it.
[DEEP EXHALE]
KIM: How do you
think that changes?
How do you make that change?
I mean, change those minds,
to get out of that old system?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Oh, gosh.
You keep banging away at it.
You keep working at it.
You don't give up.
You keep proving that it works.
You don't lose heart.
And you take solace in
that you are doing good,
and you're making
the world better.
You're leaving the place
better than you found it,
which I think is the heart of
what anybody should be doing,
if they want to get
into doing good.
KIM: You touched on it
a bit, in your talk.
But what are your long term
hopes for AmpleHarvest.org?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: I'd like
to put us out of business.
It sounds the glib to
say, because you'd never
hear many other
organizations say that.
But when you think about
it for a moment-- when
I was growing up, and
I'll be 62 in November.
When I was growing
up, people were
looking for money for
polio, and smallpox.
Anybody here get a solicitation
for either of those lately?
No.
They solved the problem,
and they went home.
And I think a good charity
should find a problem,
solve it, and go home.
Because there's
lots of other places
where money and
support is needed.
And find the problem,
be able to fix it,
or at least severely
diminish the problem.
And be done with it.
I think we can get to
a point in America,
where everybody
looks at excess food
the same way we all look
at, for example, old coats.
You get an old coat, what's the
first thing that comes to mind?
The Goodwill bin or
something else down the road.
You drop it off, hoping
that somebody else is
going to be able to use the coat
that you don't want anymore.
We should be doing that
with all of our food.
If we have more food-- and it's
not just gardeners, by the way.
But if we have more food than
we could then we can use,
we should be finding
ways, either not
to have purchased and prepared
that much in the first place;
or if we have it,
especially fresh food,
get it to people who
really, really need it.
It is a-- it's really--
forgive the pun,
it's the low hanging fruit in
solving so many of our problems
in our country.
It really is.
You get kids eating fresh food,
instead of processed food.
You get the eating potatoes,
instead of potato chips.
You get them to learn that
Apple's don't come pre-sliced
in cellophane.
You start to change the future
of how these kids grow up.
And the diabetes
and obesity problems
that is going to really hurt
this country gets thwarted.
It's not hard to do.
And it's not expensive at all.
KIM: So you are touching
the world of food, waste,
and hunger all the time,
what's the most difficult story
that you've come across?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Yeah.
You saw that list
of emails I put up?
That was a small sampling.
We get emails from people all
the time saying, I'm hungry,
I need help.
Can you help us?
And we can't actually.
That's not our role.
Remember, we're
fixing this pipeline,
from the growers
to food pantries.
We don't feed people.
We're partnered with both
WhyHunger.org and the United
Way.
WhyHunger.org particularly,
is an amazing organization.
And their job is to
connect a hungry family
to food resource in
their own community.
So we send them off that way.
But by the way, each person
that does some of those emails
gets a reply from myself
or somebody else, saying,
we're really sorry.
Here's where you can go.
One woman wrote to me,
one of those letters.
I'm having a difficult time.
I can't feed my family,
my husband's ill.
I don't remember
the details of it,
but what blew me off was
when I saw the bottom.
She was active duty US Navy.
That hurt.
That shouldn't be.
Sorry, I get choked
up about that still.
That was tough.
That was the toughest probably.
But that's what's going
on in the country.
KIM: Can you tell us
one of the best stories?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Yeah.
I actually have it
on my thing here.
I want to read it, because
it's that good a story.
This was an email
that I'd gotten,
and I hope it's still hear.
A woman who was raising a bunch
of kids, and she had let's see,
here we go-- I'm
gonna just read this.
So you can see what
this-- this was just
a wonderful,
wonderful short story.
I'm the mother of seven.
15 grandchildren and
others, that I'm mom to.
We have a garden,
that we plant for us.
But it's not enough.
She got the kids planting food.
She got the kids involved
in the gardening.
And the kids got really, really
excited about seeing the food
growing.
If you could see the garden, the
faces of the babies when they--
and quote, unquote, 'babies,'--
when they go out and the food
and the veggies for supper,
it was so wonderful for them
to get fresh veggies.
That was good for them.
One of my babies last year
ate every tomato on one plant.
These were his tomatoes.
The mom said he hated them, but
sure enough changed her mind
when he was eating them, here.
We have lemon trees, pineapple
trees, et cetera, et cetera.
Kids react to the
fact-- when they
can taste what a real piece
of produce tastes like,
it changes them.
And this kid, whoever this
kid is, is changed for life.
And this happens to millions
of kids across the country.
That's great.
That offsets the Navy lady
story, many times over.
It's really nice.
KIM: That's a great story.
That's a good one.
So what would you being doing if
you weren't doing AmpleHarvest?
GARY OPPENHEIMER:
[DEEP EXHALE] The glib answer,
is I'd be biking.
I'm a long distance biker.
KIM: I knew you were gonna--
GARY OPPENHEIMER: but
flying across country, you
can't really-- I
have other ideas
for things I'd like to do.
I've had one dream.
I figured it out.
I didn't even
figure it out, I was
taught in first grade had
end gridlock in Washington.
And it's a stupid simple idea.
I'd love to find a
way to incorporate--
stop having these people sit
here, and that people sit here.
Make Congress sit in
alphabetical order.
And I bet you problems
start to dissolve,
because people
talk to each other.
Things like that-- these are
not complex problems to solve.
They're easy to do.
And I put my energies into that.
But I'd still get the
cross country bike ride in.
KIM: OK.
Now you said that
Google has been
an immense part
of AmpleHarvest's
nationwide success.
GARY OPPENHEIMER:
Yeah, big time.
KIM: What can
individual Googlers
do to help move AmpleHarvest
to the next level?
And maybe not just
Googlers, but anybody?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: We love ideas.
We love energy.
We love people getting involved.
And funding.
I mean, one of the nice
things I said earlier,
was that Google actually
matches donations.
But this is something,
this is a viral campaign,
a viral program, frankly.
I mean, once you know
how to fix the problem
in your own community,
you can spread it
across your own community,
without having any involvement
from us.
So whether you're a
Googler, or whether you're
anybody else in the country,
spreading the word-- taking
the effort yourself not
to waste food, by the way.
And there are many-- Jonathan
Bloom, by the way, who's
part of our organization,
has an amazing book, called
'America Wasteland.
His blog is WastedFood.com.
Take a look at
it, or take a look
at that Tristram Stuart
Ted talk on food waste.
Both of these are really
good places to look to see,
what are we doing, and what
could we be doing better?
So looking at how you
doing-- what you could
do better about food waste.
But we've had people within
Google who have stepped up
and said, I'm an engineer.
I do this, and I want to help.
Vint Cerf; Carla LaFever,
who worked with him, these
are amazing who have
stepped up and said,
we want to be a part of
this and we want to help.
The help-- this is a small
organization, just so you know.
At this point, we're
three and a half people.
I mean, think about
the national impact
for three and a half people.
We're supposed to
be seven people.
That's where our half million
dollar budget actually openly
goes to, with all the
technology and everything.
It's never going to
be a big organization.
That means that people
coming in and helping out,
can be immensely helpful.
The opportunity to be a part of
the change, to make a change,
to influence a
change, is immense.
And I can't think of a
better talent of pool
then people like,
like what Google has.
I mean, people coming in
with ideas, not afraid
of innovation.
Not afraid to experiment
and risk succeeding,
I think is an amazing thing for
Google and AmpleHarvest.org.
And of course, honestly
funding support.
Any place people can find ways
to help support us financially,
will help us get past the
point of asking for money,
and doing more
with the money, is
immensely helpful to the
future, health and wealth,
as Vint put it, of America.
KIM: Thanks, Gary.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Thank you.
KIM: I think it's time to
turn it over to you guys.
So if anyone has a question,
I can pass the mic.
Or I think that's working
over there too, if you want.
I'll go on this side.
I'm just going to
walk back and forth.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: To ask a beam
counter-y question,
do you have an estimate of
the dollar value of the goods
that you've facilitated, moving
from growers to the food banks?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: No.
That's a really good question.
And I appreciate you leading
in with the bean counter type
thing.
But it's-- honestly, the dollar
value is not as important
as the nutritional value.
Because the nutritional value
represents a multiplier effect.
I'm making up a number; if
I donate $100 of tomatoes,
I've benefited the
community by $100, frankly.
But if I donate $100 worth
of health, the long term
impact of that.
In terms of the reduction
of future health issues,
many times magnifies that over.
From a metrics
perspective, I should
say that the discussion that's
always been with food has been,
how many pounds, how many meals?
I touched on that.
In the fresh food realm,
poundage doesn't really
make a lot of sense.
How are you going
to compare donations
of watermelon and spinach?
The same weight of the two,
spinach is immensely more help,
beneficial to the community and
the country then watermelon is.
One of the projects
we have lined up,
and the Clinton people
would like to see us do it,
is the Community
Nutritional Index.
The this is a model that
I have in my mind, that
takes what I used to
see in PC Magazine,
in my geeky days, which is
how you sort of measured
the relative value of
this brand of computer,
versus that brand of computer,
and apply it to fresh food.
Which would then
start to get us closer
to the financial
question you're asking.
Because under that
scenario, we can then
realize that a
pound of watermelon,
is equal to this much of this.
And look at the individual
macro and micro nutrient.
That can then get translated
to a dollar value.
One of the informal advisers
for AmpleHarvest.org
is Rear Admiral Dr.
Susan Blumenthal,
who is the former
Assistant Surgeon
General of the United States.
So we have access to a
wealth of medical input,
and health ideas
along those lines.
We've documented informally,
many, many tens of millions
of dollars of-- tens
of millions of pounds,
I'm sorry-- of food
having come in.
Why can't we give
you an exact number?
If you remember
that big green line
that came from the
gardener to the pantry?
The food doesn't
pass through us.
We don't touch the food,
there's no logistics.
We ask people to tell
us what you've donated.
But the other side
is the food pantries,
are really lousy at metrics.
They don't have scales.
We ask them how much
food, we get bags.
We get boxes.
We get bushels.
We get-- one food pantry--
we did an early survey,
and we said how many
pounds of food did you get,
did you possibly get?
This is probably in 2010, we
were less than a year old.
They said 9 million pounds.
We were seeing
numbers like none.
500 pounds.
25 pounds.
9 million?
I call this person up,
and said, is this a typo?
They said no.
No.
A farmer heard about us,
through AmpleHarvest.org,
and started bringing
truckloads of food.
How do you measure that?
Other then, it's
just-- I was stunned.
I was thrilled.
One other question about the
success of AmpleHarvest.org I
feel like I have to point out.
Because I was asked
earlier on how do you
know when you're successful?
And I said, this is has
been my true feeling.
We're successful, when
the first gardener
donates the first
delivery of food.
Everything else after is
just building on the success.
But the success was the
first time food was donated.
I hope someday we can
give you dollar number.
But I'd much rather
actually say,
this many more people don't
have colorectal cancer.
Or this many more people
don't have type 2 diabetes.
I'll let somebody
else figure out
what that's worth
to the country.
I'd like to simply say
we've saved this many lives,
or we've prolonged
this many lives.
Or we've reduced this amount
of illness in the country, OK?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Cool.
Hey, thank you,
first of all, Gary,
for sharing that story with us.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Really cool
just to hear your vision.
I was really curious
to understand-- can you
talk to us a little bit more
about some of the big problems
and challenges that you faced?
Obviously raising
money, and the old model
for thinking about
success, is something
that you've told us about.
But what are some of the other
challenges that you face,
and then maybe as
a kind of followup,
talk a little bit
more about what
an incremental or $500
thousand more can do for you.
Obviously, hiring more people.
What would those
people, maybe like,
what would those people do?
Why that number?
Well, let's start
with the first one.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: OK.
AUDIENCE: The challenges.
The challenges that you guys
face, outside of fundraising.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: OK.
The challenge-- well, in
effect-- and I alluded to this,
I think, is that we spend
enough time worrying about,
and chasing money,
that we're not
doing all the good we
can and should be doing?
And my dream scenario,
to be honest,
and I've said this--
the guy who asked
me the question about that 500
at the conference-- I followed
up with, if we got $2
million, and you came back
in four years,
we'd be able to you
the magnitude of
impact on America.
Because it's that cheap to
be that big as an influence.
Understanding something, what
AmpleHarvest.org is doing,
and what other small charities
like AmpleHarvest.org is doing,
we're not moving mountains.
And we don't have
to move a mountain.
We've put a pebble
in somebody's,
a pebble in the
shoe stops an army,
that a mountain couldn't stop.
So it doesn't take a lot to
redirect the way things are
going, to make things
actually happen.
What we would be doing with
that, is the other programs
that we want to build,
gleaningharvest.org,
Producepedia, and
Nutritional Index
would have been built by now.
Producepedia is
really very important.
This sort of came on my radar
when a teacher wrote to me.
We were probably
about a year old.
She said she brought an
apple, a cucumber and a-- I
think it was a pare or
something, into her classroom.
And most the kids have no
idea what a cucumber was.
And I suspect they knew
what the apple was,
because they
probably had iPhones.
But really people are
disconnected from the food.
And so the idea
behind Producepedia,
what we want to
build, is something
whereby we will have a database
of all the foods people grow.
And I'm not just saying apples
and carrots and oranges,
I'm talking about very,
very, very granularly.
I grow tomatoes.
Now, we all have tomatoes.
You have the red tomatoes,
and the yellow tomatoes,
and the cherry tomatoes.
And there are-- anybody
see an Icelandic tomato?
No.
They're white. krim tomatoes?
Black.
So if I were to bring
Icelandic tomatoes into a food
pantry, or a krim one, which
is black, people would say,
I don't know.
The idea behind Producepedia
is to create a print out,
a simple print
out, that not only
says what the food is, with
a picture, inside, outside.
But some basic
information about it,
so that the pantry
and the people,
they would know what
they're getting.
And what to do with it.
Do you eat it raw?
Do you cook it?
Or whatever.
So the food wouldn't
go to waste.
I grew purple carrots
one year, my wife
didn't know what to
do with the stuff.
So you can imagine what
it's like on a larger scale.
The programs are lined
up, that I want to build.
The staffing is what's
needed to actually expand
AmpleHarvest.org, to its
full potential impact.
Just to give you an
idea of-- the staff
consists of one
person whose full time
work is to work
with the pantries.
And every pantry that
signs up, all 7,000,
have been vetted by this person.
Or by somebody in her position.
We want to make sure,
when a pantry signs up,
that it's really a pantry.
And if it fits our criteria
of giving food away for free,
and being a nonprofit.
That it's not something
it shouldn't really be.
So we're verifying each one.
The other one, she's
involved in reaching out
to the gardeners across America,
saying the solution to hunger
is in your backyard.
I'm there, sort of
running the whole thing,
and trying to push
the message out.
And we have a part time admin.
We need a few more people to
do the stuff, the technology,
and all the other pieces
that are in there.
But Producepedia would
be the final step
in making sure that
people at the pantry
make the best use of the food.
The gleaningharvest.org,
as I said,
will dwarf
AmpleHarvest.org, in terms
of the amount of food
coming into the system.
If you look at the end NRDC
reports-- and if, by the way,
anybody who wants to
see the presentation,
if you go to
AmpleHarvest.org/googletechtalk,
it'll be a PDF you
can freely downloaded.
It's available right now.
The gleaningharvest.org,
is going to connect people
to organizations they
never we knew existed.
I go into places all the
time full of foodies,
and I say do you know gleaners
or gleaning organizations?
Many people don't.
It's in the Old Testament,
Book of Ruth, Deuteronomy,
you know, leave the
food in the corners,
in the edges of your fields.
Don't pick up what
you drop, it's
for the poor, the
widow, and the traveler.
We have organizations
in this country that
are volunteers, people, and
most important, insurance,
who will come to farm or
your community garden,
harvest the food, and get it to
the people who really need it.
Except nobody knows they exist.
We want to build the bridge,
built on Google Maps,
that's going to
connect the people
with these organizations, bring
them together, and again, once
that connection's
made, its permanent.
And then when after
the farmer harvests
the fields, and x percent of
the celery, of the potatoes
are left, or the apple orchard,
and a whole lot of apples
are left down,
volunteers can come in,
and that food gets
into the system.
I went to visit a food bank
in Israel's assistance called
Leket Israel, and I was--
they have magnificent gleaning
operations.
It's the gold standard
for the world.
And I was stunned.
Nothing in that food
bank was processed food,
with one exception.
Israelis have this thing about
this thick chocolate spread.
But everything else
was fresh produce
that have been gleaned from
farms across the country.
And that's getting
into a system.
And we can and should
be doing it here.
And gleaningharvest.org
is exactly where
I want to get that
particular thing done.
Did I answer your question?
I want to make sure.
OK.
Is there another question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Hi.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: HI.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming today.
This is really
interesting to learn.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: My
pleasure, thank you.
AUDIENCE: You've
clearly done a great job
of getting a lot of national
attention to your organization.
And as someone who works with
nonprofit outside of work,
I was wondering what's your
advice for, to do that?
Did any of-- was it impacted
by the first lady's agenda?
Do you think that helped?
GARY OPPENHEIMER: [DEEP EXHALE]
That's a great question.
I will tell you in all
honesty, one of the big things
was believe it or
not, Google Alerts.
I would have a flood
of those coming in,
and I had pre-scanned
emails ready to go, back out
to reporters, news
stations, whatever saying,
great story on food pantries.
Great story on hunger.
Great story on this,
here's a site for followup,
for another story.
And we have a really
good online press kit.
The funny thing about
the first lady's office,
is that she rolled out Let's
Move! in, I think early 2010.
And I wrote a letter
to the White House,
saying I got this
great new program.
We'd love to partner with you.
And somebody wrote back and
said, thanks, but no thanks.
Fine.
No problem.
Christmas time,
2011, my wife and I
had the privilege of being
invited to the White House
to meet the president
and first lady.
So it was a thing of keep
at it, keep working at it.
It was actually
connections, ultimately
through the USDA, that got
us into the White House.
We'd been going after
the Clinton Foundation.
And we were getting pushed
back, pushed back, pushed
Back.
This past January, I was
with President Clinton,
and AmpleHarvest.org
is a strategic partner
of the Clinton Foundation--
the Clinton Foundation's Health
Matter Initiative.
You keep at it.
And honestly, if you're
not succeeding here,
just go another way.
The heart of
AmpleHarvest.org actually
is, when you hit a roadblock,
take a different path.
Which is strangely enough, the
underpinnings of the internet.
I mean, when you're
sending information,
if this node is down,
route it around that node.
It's not really any different.
The other thing is, and this
is something that the man that
Vint and I both, I guess worked
under at MCI-- his saying,
which I've adopted, is
to do the impossible,
you must first believe it isn't.
His name is Bob [INAUDIBLE].
I have an ashtray with that
on there, I treasure it.
It's really, really
important that if you believe
in something, whether
it's in the not for profit
or the for-profit
world, stick to it.
Be true to it.
If it's the right
thing, it'll happen.
It may not happen as big or
as gloriously as you wanted.
In my case, this happened far
bigger, and more gloriously
than I had ever expected.
I mean, I'm an aging geek.
I have no background
in the nonprofit world.
And I'm at a point now
where I'm talking to you.
I've met two presidents.
I go around the country
giving speeches.
There's been a long
litany of things
that six years ago, I
would've never expected.
The thing to do is also to
[DEEP EXHALE] find people
who believe the
same thing you do.
Invite them, partner
like crazy, by the way.
Stick to your mission.
That's super critical.
There's something
called mission creep.
Never go down that path.
If you believe-- if your mission
is to do this, stick to it,
and find partners
to do nearby things.
But don't drift
into their stuff.
We've done that.
We don't help people get food.
We go to WhyHunger or National
Hunger Hotline, or United Way.
That's their job.
We don't tell
people how to grow.
National Gardening Association
does a great job, as do others.
We are that connector between
the food in the community,
and the need in the community.
And we're educating,
encouraging,
and enabling millions
of growers to donate.
By the result of doing
that-- I hate the expression,
but we own the
space that were in.
People are using
us as a resource
to do their different
things, which is great.
There's a new student
group in Florida
that's doing a food
recovery thing,
and they're using
AmpleHarvest.org's resources
to help them do their stuff.
And our model is now
with our systems,
being replicated
around the world.
I've met with people in--
well, I shouldn't say in.
I've been to Greece and Israel.
But all this I've either
emailed, Skype or whatever,
England, Poland, the UK, South
Africa, Japan, New Zealand,
Australia, I missing a few.
And we're making this
information freely available.
This is how it
works, in America.
Make it work in your system,
in your language, your culture,
whatever, in your country.
The food waste issue is
not an American problem.
I like the way Tristram
Stuart brilliantly shows,
it is a global problem.
But there's also a
global opportunity.
We've got a model
that was perfectly fit
for the American food
distribution network.
It was built for that.
And also, one other thing, and
I should've said this earlier,
so I'm going to say it now.
Think about other areas where
you can influence things,
in the work you're
doing, that you
wouldn't have thought about.
I built AmpleHarvest.org
with something called 'just
in time' inventory.
And in manufacturing,
just in time inventory
is something-- having pieces
arrive just when you need them.
When Boeing's
making an airplane,
they have the wings
arrive just when it's
ready to be attached
to the fuselage.
It's not sitting on the side.
So things come just in time.
AmpleHarvest.org harvest
was built in a way in which,
we tell the pantries to tell
the growers when to come.
And by the way, this
one little speck
changes a whole bunch of things.
We told the pantries,
tell the growers
to come an hour or two
before the clients come
to pick up the food.
Now what happens as
a result of that?
Well, number one is the food
comes in, stays a few hours,
and goes out.
We've eliminated the need for
refrigeration and storage.
That was a huge
impediment for pantries
nationwide to take fresh food.
We have no place to store
it, we have no place
to refrigerate it.
In, out same day basis,
no refrigeration.
But there's an ethical
component to it too.
In our society,
it's entirely likely
that I'm growing more
food than I can use,
and you're my next door neighbor
who has fallen on hard times.
And you're going
to a food pantry,
you're kind of
humiliated as it is.
You wish you could take care
of your own family better,
and you didn't need
to use a pantry.
You shouldn't feel
that way, but you do.
The worst thing is for
me to be showing up
with my basket of
food, you showing up
to pick up your thing,
and I'm embarrassed,
and you're humiliated.
By separating by time,
I'm coming in a few hours
before you, I know it's
going to my community,
but I don't know who.
You know it came
from your community,
but you don't know who.
The ethics in that's
really, really important.
The food moves, they use
no refrigeration, storage,
and our relationship has
nothing to this whole thing.
You can find other ways to make.
And those things alone
excite other people.
That gets people informed--
wow, I can do these things too.
And the last thing I would
say is, share your knowledge.
I love talking at universities.
Not because I like to
talk, although I do.
It's because I like to listen.
And the students come back to
me, some really great ideas
and really, really
great questions.
And some of them have
jazzed up things,
and we've added things
on AmpleHarvest.org.
Somebody came to us with an
idea that we never thought
about, and fits, and we do it.
So share the knowledge.
Share the information.
Share your successes.
Share your failures.
And I'm happy to
talk you further
about it, if you want--
whatever your endeavors is.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
GARY OPPENHEIMER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]